how does China decide where they invest
into their military how does Russia
decide where to invest into the military
if we were to pull up our top five
biggest enemies
how did they make the decision on where
the money is being invested in are they
unified in the decisions that's being
made there versus in America
it's political what the Investments are
being made I mean we're living in an era
right now which I don't know if you
agree with this or not according to you
know some of our guys whether you want
to talk about Kirby whether you want to
talk about you know many of the generals
we have today the super soldier today is
part of the lgbtq community you know
today's uh super soldier is is got to be
a trans because you know we're we're
learning I mean that's the way to go
right and imagine the amount of
innovation and research we've done to
realize that the best soldiers are them
but I want to know how my enemy
decides the budget do they sit in a room
and they're fully unified do they sit in
a room and they say hey how about we
make that company BlackRock all this
money how about we get this contract to
Raytheon north of Grumman how about we
get these guys that 30 years ago we had
50 different companies that we bought
military recruitment from that they
bought each other there's only five of
them left today
you know why don't we we need that guy's
money for campaign distribution what
that's the part I have a concern with
because if we're gonna make these
Investments like this that's going to
benefit a company out there well we're
not really protecting this country we're
just figuring out a way to get
re-elected and get more campaign
donations oh listen now you've broken
the code there's no question about it
and it's it's useful to just pause for a
second and talk about the Chinese
dilemma
people are imputing all sorts of things
to China right now they they are
magically uh shipping all the fentanyl
to the United States no they're selling
fentanyl to the drug cartels and it's
not the government it's organized crime
in China actually that's involved in
this and the organized crime problem in
China is enormous
there are 1.4 billion Chinese
and every morning ji does not wake up
and think about how he can defeat the
United States he wakes up and wonders
how he can stay in power how he can
manage this chaotic mess how he can hold
it together
I mean he just destroyed the shadow
banking industry in China That's
beginning to have a terrible effect on
the economy
because Shadow banking was the source of
many of the loans that were necessary to
sustain growth
they got a growth problem in China they
have a huge corruption problem in China
a few months a few years ago they
arrested and then ultimately executed as
I understand it the man who's
responsible for shipbuilding because he
was deliberately overseeing the uh a
building of faulty holes in the pla Navy
you know everybody says well this is a
300 ship Navy and China has outstripped
us 100 of those vessels are Coast Guard
vessels nobody ever brings that up
nobody ever brings up the fact that
Chinese really don't like to go to Sea
they don't want to be out there it's not
a seafaring Nation
they have just started a submarine Fleet
that is nuclear and nuclear capable well
we've been doing that since the 1950s it
takes decades to build a force like that
to train the people to organize them and
equip them effectively
China has huge problems just holding
itself together
so I think we should set China aside and
understand that it is not this
Juggernaut that is Led in one particular
direction
I would see it as a nation that has to
feed itself to feed itself it has to
have Commerce to have Commerce a lot of
that has to go over land or oversea
those things are real but that doesn't
mean that it's a juggernaut bent on war
with anybody
now let's turn to Russia which is a a
smaller entity and it's easier to
understand I think uh pujin was
responsible for tearing apart reducing
and trying to modernize the old Soviet
military structure the old Soviet
military structure was enormous you know
they had over a million men under arms
at just the Soviet Army they had vast
stores of equipment most of the stuff
had long since become obsolete this is
the problem when you try to modernize a
large Force you can't do it without
facing the very high probability that 10
years after you've modernized it it's
hopelessly Obsolete and you have no
savings with which to do anything else
so he tried to make it smaller and he
succeeded he made it much more he tried
to professionalize it he tried to stop
the brutality inside the old army
barracks which was so characteristic not
just to the Soviet military but also the
Zara stormies
he had some success then it turns out
that he had to use it
and it was too small for the purpose
that he decided to use it for so now
it's up to 750 000 there's a plan to
make it 1.2 million
congratulations President Biden
congratulations NATO you just created
the very thing that you said you were
setting out to stop
did you understand
uh and so in in Russia one man at the
top with the defense minister has
enormous power
he has much more power than Biden much
more power than almost anybody else who
sits in that position to allocate
resources to establish factories to
disestablish factories to build new
formations to disestablish Old
formations
think of Putin not as Stalin but as a
czar
he is roughly as powerful today as the
Czar of Russia was before World War one
that's the kind of power and influence
he wields
and I'm sure he's under a lot of
criticism right now because there are
always people in Russia that say we need
a bigger Force we need a bigger Force
they border how many countries how many
thousands of miles across is the place
I mean you know it's it's
legitimate but he he tried very hard to
economize now he's stuck with the
requirement to maintain a much larger
more lethal military force and you
wonder how how long until you know the
whole thing about 40 Laws of Power I
don't know if you've read 40 Laws of
Power Robert Greene rule number one
never outshine the master there's always
somebody that's looking for you to fall
so they can kind of take over your
position you're sitting there saying
these guys are probably even in the mob
it happens all the time where you know
Paul Castellano is the boss and then
John Gotti and Sammy the bull hey y'all
kind of want to take the throne and then
John becomes the boss and then hey is
Sammy going to want to do the same thing
I did to Paul
there may be a little bit of that
paranoia in him as well for how long can
I really keep this thing together people
are now Rich they not have money more
than they've ever had before people were
not this Rich they are richer than ever
before so those are certain concerns and
fears that they have happy Fourth of
July too we have a special event that's
coming up with Tom Brady Mike Tyson and
we'll get there in Miami ball conference
it'll be August 30th to September 2nd
this weekend for Fourth of July we're
running a special buy one get one free
bring your spouse bring your business
partner bring your running mate if you
haven't yet registered click on the link
below or above get registered looking
forward to spending three days with you
in Miami
foreign
[Music]